ايران توظف الاراضي السوريه لخدمه انظمتها
الصاروخيه والهجمات الاسرائيليه الاخيره
على سوريا كان الهدف منها افشالوا مشروع
ايراني هناك صحيفه نيوز ويك خاضت بشكل
دقيق في تفاصيل هذا المشروعه حيث كشفت ان
الامر يتعلق بمشروع مشترك بين ايران وقوه
النظام السوري بهدف زرع نظام ايراني مستقل
للدفاع الجوي من داخل سوريا ويقوم المشروع
الايراني على انشائي منصات للصواريخ
ووضعيه اجهزه رادار المتطوره باستخدام
احدث الاسلحه الايرانيه ياتي في مقدمتها
صاروخ صياد هانتر الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب
والذي تم الكشف عنه في نوفمبر الماضي فضلا
عن نظامي ثلاثه سبعه ثلاثه المضاد
للطائرات والذي يغطي دائره يزيد قطرها عن
280 ميلانا اسرائيل من جهاتها اختارت
التصدي لتهديد الايرانيه القادم من سوريا
من خلال غارات هنا بدات منذ سنه 2017
وكانت المطارات هدفا اساسيا لهذه القارات
اهمها مطار دمشق الذي تعرض لسبع غارات
اسرائيليه خلال العام الماضي وحدها مشروع
طهران اذا في بناء حصن جوي في سوريا لم
يتحقق وتل ابيب لا تبدو مستعده للسماح
بذلك وسما ذهبي العربي